here's an important picture I should be
painted a lot of people are saying you
know Crowder you recorded uh Jeremy
that's not what friends do they're
surprised by it but here's here's what
I'm seeing now and uh you know putting
myself in the middle of this
you you're always in the middle of it of
course that's what I do right but but
look you you go to the doctor no no no
your term sheet okay you go to the Daily
wire they say here's a term sheet you go
whoa this is crazy hey you can't do this
the daily wire then says all of a sudden
but a few months later Crowder register
stop VidCon then he calls and secretly
records Jeremy he was setting us up this
email right here paints a different
picture in that you talked with the
daily wire and said here's our issue
here's what we can't do and they said
okay and then sometime later they try no
they said if that's the issue this is
our business model and you don't know
business but then they try and poach one
of your employees one of your and that
could be an accident
but it's not the first time